welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the most surprising element of
dr strange's multiverse of madness was
the exact way it connected the dots
between the marvel multiverse in the
x-men continuity with patrick stewart
charles xavier quoting himself from the
2014 x-men days of future past telling
616 stephen strange just because someone
stumbles and loses their way doesn't
mean they're lost forever in days of
future past xavier said these same words
to his past self from 1973 played by
james mcavoy via wolverine's time
traveling consciousness eric was right
humanity does this to us not if we show
them a better path
you still believe just because someone
stumbles loses their way it doesn't mean
they're lost forever
sometimes we all need a little help so
it's interesting for multiverse of
madness to quote the line like it's some
kind of absolute constant among all
charles xavier variants the way the with
great power quote is a constant among
peter parker variants really while it's
a very cool thematic parallel it's not
like these have been considered the
immortal words of the professor charles
xavier now the 838 charles xavier is
obviously inspired greatly by the 1990s
animated professor x with the yellow
hover chair the green suit the blue
striped tie the ron wasserman theme
music but when it comes to which of the
live action fox x-men films that the
marvel studios team looked to it really
does seem like they picked up with
2014's x-men days of future past
specifically there is some convincing
evidence the bright happy ending future
restored timeline at the end of days of
future past could be the same reality of
the 838 universe in multiverse of
madness maybe even a reality similar to
the version of the x-men that we saw in
that 90s animated series so let's break
down how this could all connect and what
it would mean for the mcu so if you have
not seen x-men days of future past i
cannot recommend it enough it's one of
the essential fox x-men films and hot
take it was an epic crossover event that
handled timelines and multiverse logic
better than avengers endgame did better
than spider-man no way home did and
better than doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness did now does that
mean jason future passes a better movie
than those other three maybe not really
its legacy has been shaded by a few not
as great x-men movies that followed it
but for one brief moment the convoluted
timeline of the whole x-men franchise
crystallized in such an elegant way in
this movie that i think it's epilogue
deserves to be among the mcu multiverse
elseworlds so a quick recap the 2000s
x-men films led by hugh jackman patrick
stewart e mckellen led to two spin-off
series the wolverine solo films and then
a rebooted x-men timeline with james
mcavoy and michael fassbender in x-men
first class then in 2014 the casts of
both timelines combined and days of
future past which was set initially in
an apocalyptic future in 2023
in which the older cast of mutants send
wolverine back in time by displacing his
consciousness into his younger body back
in 1973 so that he can stop this darkest
timeline from unfolding in 1973 we meet
evan peters peter maximoff quick silver
magneto's sun and this movie ends with
that dark future being averted in that
future timeline in the year 2023 being
restored and warped to a peaceful future
erasing the deaths from x-men the last
stand so this future now has wolverine
and charles xavier cyclops jean grey
storm kitty pride colossus beast iceman
all these characters alive and so too
presumably magneto and mystique and in
this scene logan and charles have an
interesting exchange
you did it
did what logan don't you have a class to
teach
a class to teach
history
history
actually i could use some help with that
help with what
pretty much everything after
1973. i think the history i know is a
little different
welcome back
yes very reminiscent of dumbledore
italian time traveling harry and
hermione well
he's free we did it did what
good night so when patrick stewart had
that line it really was the magic of
stewart in this role charles always
seems to know everything his vast brain
interwoven with a multiverse of his
alternate selves here the implication
was that older charles had some
alternate life offscreen of memories
with logan all that time knowing the two
had crossed paths in 1973 but he never
brought it up until now that
consciousness suddenly returned to logan
in the year 2023 so after this the x-men
movies stayed with the 1973 cast with
x-men apocalypse set in the 80s and dark
phoenix set in the 90s but we never
checked back in with that peaceful 2023
timeline it was really presented as a
happy ending send-off to that original
cast but then we got the movie logan
which was the third of the wolverine
solo films that was set in the year 2029
and it was suggested that all the other
x-men besides logan and charles xavier
were killed off but director james
mangled would not specify whether logan
was set in the days of future past 2023
epilogue timeline if anything it seems
to be a western set in its own elseworld
universe it's so tonally removed from
being a superhero movie at all kind of
what makes it so great honestly one of
my favorite parts of analyzing dr
strange the multiverse of madness has
been the awesome way i've been able to
stay hydrated during this process thanks
to our friends at g fuel i just got a
delivery of the not yet released orange
madness hydration collector's box from
g-fuel inspired by marvel studios doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
this collector's box comes with a
hydration tub and a 16 ounce shaker cup
it's releasing in june but you can get
on the waitlist by clicking the link in
this video's description okay let's try
it out i just filled this with some
water taking a scoop of this orange
madness flavor putting it in the water
giving it a shaky shaky shaker
and taking a sip
oh so orange madness has a sweet blood
orange flavoring it's got no calories no
sugar it's also caffeine free if you're
not looking for that particular kind of
madness it has focused aminos and a
bunch of antioxidants and vitamins to
keep you hydrated no matter what you are
doing if you're making videos if you're
gaming if you're trying to keep the
scarlet witch from unraveling the
multiverse so click the link in the
description to get on the waitlist for
the orange madness collectors box and
use code new rockstars to get 30 off and
thanks again to g fuel for sponsoring
this video and when we look back at that
days of future past 2023 epilogue it was
really meant to evoke marty mcfly waking
up to a warped 1985 and back to the
future logan similarly wakes up to that
same alarm clock song but now there's a
hologram display classroom c passes also
use holotech something the earlier set
x-men movies did not use charles xavier
for the first time in the x-mansion uses
an actual hover chair and that hover
chair and the quoted line in multiverse
of madness just because someone stumbles
to me these details were enough to make
me at least wonder if 838 could be that
same days of future past epilogue
timeline a timeline advanced even
further into the future the a38 that we
visit in this movie once the x-men had
crossed paths with the fantastic war in
the avengers of that universe and fought
in their own infinity war conflict with
thanos now that would mean 838 is now a
universe where professor x has been
killed by the scar of the witch and the
x-men left behind to avenge him would
include that lineup of hugh jackman
james marston halle berry vanky jensen
and mckellen all of them had at wanda
maximoff now that's not to say that
those x-men would be the main x-men
lineup in the mcu's 616 future but it
would leave the door open to one
universe in the mcu multiverse where
those actors could exist and could come
back it would also change our
understanding of the 838 wanda's
parentage in 616 wand and pietro were
born to oleg and arena maximoff and
sokovia but in the x-men continuity evan
peters quicksilver was the son of
magneto eric lyncher and it's
interesting to note that 838 wanda's
west view house which is a real
structure that exists in that universe
looks exactly like wanda's dream house
that she conjured out of magic in
episodes six through eight of one
division and within that magical hex
wanda's brother pietro was evan peters
now yes episode 9 suggested that he was
actually a local new jersey actor ralph
boner puppeted by agatha but i mean all
those reveals still came within the hex
those headshots his appearance his
identity was presented while the hex was
still active we never saw him on the
other side of the hex before or after
now i don't want to hinge all of my
theories on whatever ralph was meant to
be in one division but it is at least
possible that if wanda had evan peters
as her brother in the hex that in
another reality where everything else
about her suburban life looked the same
as in the hex that he might also be
there now some have been pointing at
this framed photo in 838 wanda's home
it's hard to make out but the person in
the photo does look like their arms are
raised in a similar pose to michael
fassbender magneto in days of future
past in 1973 during the battle in front
of the white house when he pointed all
the news cameras at himself so there
would be photographic evidence of that
moment so does one have a frame photo of
her papa i guess the question would be
why would 838 wanda have a photo of her
dad during this controversial incident
framed in their home like look billy and
tommy it's your pop-pop when he tried to
pop out president nixon in the 70s but
elizabeth olsen was asked by geek
culture about magneto being her dad in
the comics your father is magneto now
multiverse anything can happen
if you had the choice
who would be your daddy of choice it
would be sir ian mckellen or michael
fassbender
i'm going to go with sir ann mckellen
i had the biggest crush on him he's in
these videos called playing shakespeare
where he actors get together and they do
a shakespeare um it's a video series
and he's like the sexiest man in the
world
wow
and so i would i would say sir ian
mckellen
and ian mckellen responded to this on
facebook that it would be a treat to be
or daddy either way marvel's big agenda
by bringing back these legacy actors is
really to adopt all past marvel
universes as part of this wider
multiverse so even if it wasn't the
intent to make 838 a continuation of the
days of future past epilogue marvel feel
free to pretend it was you'll make me
look smart follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss follow me rock stars
subscribe to narc stars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you